Christian!
Let's go!
Good evening and welcome.
My name is Kat.
My pronouns are she and her, and we are so glad that you're here, whether this is your
first time or your first time in a long time.
We are so glad that you chose to be with us on this cold holiday weekend.
Since our rental situation for Christmas makes our Christmas Eve service a little challenging,
we are going to have our Christmas Eve service on December 21st, which is a Sunday at 5,
so it's a regular church service.
We will have a family-friendly service with carols and candle lighting.
Please mark your calendars to join us for our Christmas Eve service.
If you are interested in learning more about what baptism means, we will have information
classes on December 7th and 14th before service.
The baptism service will be held on Sunday, January 11th.
Please RSVP by scanning the QR code.
December 28th, which is the Sunday right after Christmas, we will not be having service
in order to give our volunteers a break in family time.
We will see you the following Sunday for Story Sunday on January 4th.
If you are anxious about being in a church setting, or you're just part of a disability
community, or just feeling fidgety today, we have an accessibility bucket right over
there that you are welcome to.
There's fidget devices, there's coloring sheets, and there's noise-canceling earplugs.
So you may pick it up if you'd like, and then please return it on your way out.
These candles are a sign of the presence of Christ among us, fully divine and fully
human.
Now we exit the kingdom of noise, hurry, and productivity.
Now we enter the kingdom of silence, stillness, and grace.
Now we enter sacred space.
A space for prayer, worship, and adoration.
A space to encounter Christ, revelation of God, heartbeat of creation.
Allow the unforced rhythms of grace to find you, to mend your heart.
And may we all come home.
If you guys want to stand with us, our worship today, I got to be honest, I really wish this
piano binge was a little bit longer, because my comfort zone is to sit right beside my
sister at our home on our piano, and to play and sing music together, and that is how we
prepared this set, and if there was enough space for both of our butts on this bench,
that is where I would be, and we would be watching this sheet music, and you guys would
all be on couches, or in sweats, you know?
That is what I'm envisioning in my head, just this idea of sinking into the comfort and
the love of God tonight.
So I hope that you guys can join us there, imagine your favorite place at your house,
or maybe somewhere else that you feel at home, and put yourself into that kind of mindset
tonight as we worship together, because wherever you feel most at home, wherever you are most
yourself, God's love is so good, and he sees us there, and he wants that for us.
He wants us to come home to ourselves, to the people he made us to be, so I hope that
we can all kind of enter that space together tonight.
Wrong song.
That is not the song.
That's not the song.
But that also does feel very much at home right there, that's something that we would
have done, and probably did earlier today.
This is going to be a day for singing, alright?
Everybody, Magdalene.
Mercy, rising with the rising of the sun.
Goodness, rationing and filling up my lungs.
Your faithfulness is here and now.
The evidence is all around.
I bless your name, I give you praise.
Today is a day for singing.
Awake my soul, come on and praise the Lord.
Oh my soul, praise the Lord.
Oh my soul, today is a day for singing.
A new song, it's welling up from deep inside of me.
New life, hallelujah, I have been redeemed.
I've been redeemed.
I bless your name, I give you praise.
Today is a day for singing.
Awake my soul, come on and praise the Lord.
Oh my soul, praise the Lord.
Oh my soul, today is a day for singing.
Today is a day for singing.
From the valley to the mountain, the desert to the fountain.
Oh, I will praise you.
From the morning to the evening, as long as I am breathing.
Today is a day for singing.
From the valley to the mountain, the desert to the fountain.
Oh, I will praise you.
From the morning to the evening, as long as I am breathing.
Today is a day for singing.
I bless your name, I give you praise.
Awake my soul, come on and praise the Lord.
Today is a day for singing.
Oh my soul, praise the Lord.
Oh my soul, today is a day for singing.
Today is a day for singing.
From the mountain to the valley, the desert to the fountain.
Oh, I will praise you.
From the morning to the evening, as long as I am breathing.
Today is a day for singing.
Alright, you kids are dismissed to go to your classes.
And your teachers will meet you over by the doors.
And we are going to move into something that we call
Prayers of the People.
You can follow along on the screens.
The parts in red we will read aloud together.
Jesus, for this city of Sachse, Texas, and for every city and community
and all who live in them, we pray to you.
For the good earth you have given us and the wisdom and the will
to conserve it, we pray to you.
For the old and the sick, for the widow and the orphan,
for the injured and suffering, we pray to you.
For the poor and the oppressed, the unemployed
and destitute, for prisoners and captives
and all who remember and care for them, we pray to you.
For the vulnerable, the marginalized, and those unjustly
targeted for their gender, sexuality, race,
or other perceived difference, we pray to you.
For those experiencing loss, loneliness, and disconnection
and for those struggling with mental and emotional health,
we pray to you. Lord, we know that you love us
and that you hear us, so we lift these names and situations
up to you.
For the names and the moments that we have spoken aloud and for those that we have kept
in our hearts, we pray to you that they may have life
and light, healing and hope,
peace, and a deep sense of your presence.
Amen.
♪
You broke my chains
of sin and shame and you covered
me with grace.
You lit my life with your holy
fire. You covered me with
grace. You are the
hand that reaches out to save.
I am set free.
It is
your freedom that I
am set free.
You
broke my chains of sin
and shame and you covered me
with grace. You
mend my life with your holy
fire. You covered me with
grace. You are the hand that
reaches out to save. I am set
free.
I am set free.
It is for
freedom that I am
set free.
I am set free.
I am set
free.
It is for freedom
that I am set
free.
Yes, Lord, we
are grateful for your
grace and for your love.
Yes, Lord, we
are grateful for your grace
and for your love.
Yes, Lord, we are
grateful for your grace
and for your love.
Yes, Lord, we are grateful
for your grace and for
your love. You are the
hand that reaches out to save.
Because your glory is so beautiful.
I fall
onto my knees in awe.
And the heartbeat of my life
is to worship in your light.
Your glory is so beautiful.
Your glory is
so beautiful.
Oh.
My life is yours.
My hope is in you only.
My heart you hold.
Because you made this sinner
holy and holy.
Holy.
Because your glory is so beautiful.
I fall onto
my knees in awe.
And the heartbeat of my life
is to worship in your light.
Your glory is so beautiful.
Your glory is so
beautiful.
Oh.
Glory, glory.
Hallelujah.
Jesus, you are good.
Glory, glory.
Hallelujah.
Jesus, you are good.
Oh, we sing glory, glory.
Hallelujah.
Jesus, you are good.
Oh, glory, glory.
Hallelujah.
Jesus, you are good.
I am set free.
Oh.
Verses 6-9 read,
Pray for the peace of Jerusalem.
May they prosper who love you.
Peace be within your walls
and security within your towers.
For the sake of my relatives
and friends, I will say,
Peace be within you.
For the sake of the house of the Lord our God,
I will seek your good.
What a beautiful prayer.
And yet I read this and I couldn't help
but to think of the way that peace
is not in fact within
Jerusalem's walls and towers
today.
Jerusalem has been in its latest
conflict for more than a year
now, beginning more than
a year ago from an assault from Hamas
in October of 2024.
But what causes me more dissonance
is to wonder
how to pray for the peace of
Jerusalem when Israel
has itself become a perpetrator
of great violence and death
against so many Palestinians
in Gaza.
I want to pray for peace and for the good of Gaza
who Israel would consider
an enemy.
More dissonance.
I turn next to the New Testament text
from Romans 13 in verses
11 and 12. The Apostle
Paul writes, Salvation
is nearer to us
than when we became believers
first. The night is far
gone. The day
is near.
Is it really, Paul?
The night is far
gone? Did that really
come true? With all
that's going on in the world some 2,000
years later, with the violence
against undocumented immigrants,
with the scapegoating and
unjust treatment of our transgender
siblings, with all the
war and atrocity that we've already
mentioned, it feels like
we are in the dead of night, bro.
Surely
Jesus has something helpful to say.
The Gospel text is from Matthew
24, where Jesus talks
about what some interpret as
the rapture. Two will be in
the field, one will be taken, the other left.
Two women will be grinding meal
together, one will be taken, the other left.
I am so glad that Brett
solved all the problems of the rapture in the
eschatology series this fall, so
I can just move right past that
to Jesus' punchline
where he says,
you don't know when the Lord is coming,
so stay awake, be alert,
be ready. The Son of Man is coming
at an hour you don't
expect. I don't
know about you, but this text
brings all my hell trauma right
to the surface.
Be ready or else Jesus will
get you. Don't misbehave
because Jesus might
return right in the middle of it.
I can hear that old Gospel preacher
stoking fear
to get folks to comply and obey
with the church's moral norms.
I mean, the Son of Man is even compared
to a thief who comes in the middle
of the night to rob someone.
Stay awake so you don't get robbed.
That's not a heartwarming
image.
More
dissonance. Sorry
to be such a downer, y'all.
Maybe, just
maybe you feel some of
this dissonance yourself.
The dissonance
between the world we
currently live in
and the world that is promised
to arrive one day.
It seems
better to be honest
about the dissonance
than to try to spiritually bypass
it or to sugarcoat
it or ignore
it. This dissonance
is exactly where I
long for God to meet
me, to meet us
in this Advent
season. What would it look
like for God to meet
us in the midst of this dissonance?
To hold this dissonance
with us? To lead
us through it
instead of around it?
That's exactly what I
wondered as I sat with these
texts. God, what do we do with this?
What's your
invitation to us in the midst
of dissonance like this?
What does it look like for us to
faithfully anticipate your
arrival in this
Advent season?
I'll admit that I came to
these texts with some ideas
about what we might do with
the dissonance instead of avoiding it
to move through it, to let God sit
with us in it,
to lament the dissonance
to God,
to share our frustration and
confusion and even anger with
God. Lament, after all, is a
very common response to dissonance
in the Psalms.
And certainly I commend lament
as a healing practice.
But as I read
through the texts again
and again, I began to notice something
else that addressed this
dissonance, that gave me
something to hold on
to. Jesus
mentions it in Matthew 24 when he
says, keep awake,
be ready. Paul
mentions it in Romans 13
when he says, let us walk
decently as in
the day. Put on
the Lord Jesus
Christ. And what do you know?
There it is at the end of
our Isaiah text.
O house of Jacob,
come, let us
walk in the light
of the Lord.
What I hear Jesus
and Paul and Isaiah saying
is that one way we can
respond to this
dissonance is with our
lives. By
embodying here and now
in the midst of the dumpster
fire of things,
the future peace and
goodness and justice
for which we long.
That's what Isaiah means
when he invites Israel to walk
in the light of the Lord, to walk
in the ways of God,
to embody in the present
the peace and justice
that is coming more fully
in the future when all
will stream to the mountain of God
and be instructed in God's ways,
when humanity will repurpose
its war weapons into
creation tools.
What if walking in the light
of the Lord means that
we go ahead and start
living the future
now?
What if the most faithful form
of waiting is practicing
the good way of Jesus
right now?
To put on the Lord
Jesus Christ, as Paul says.
The vibe of
this invitation is not that it's all
up to us, as if God's not
going to do it and so we've got to create a different
world on our own kind of thing.
What if God is already
doing it? What if God has
always been doing it?
What if God's
at work to heal and
renew and restore and our
invitation is to
participate in it?
Isaiah's invitation
after all is to walk by the light
of the Lord.
We don't have to generate the light.
The light doesn't begin with
us. We just have to find it
and walk in it.
Neither is the vibe
of this invitation to
walk in the light of the Lord or
else.
Thanks be to God. Contrary
to my anxieties. Or
else God will get us. Or else God
will judge us and send us to hell.
It's more like the plea of
someone who loves us all
so dearly. Please.
Please walk
in the light
because the fruit of walking in the
light is light.
And the fruit of walking in darkness
is darkness. What
fruit do we want?
God doesn't coerce
or threaten us.
The plea comes to us
as an invitation to participate.
To join in what the
spirit of God is doing. To clothe
ourselves with the character
and action
of Jesus.
This invitation reminds me of something I've
heard my co-director in the
Healing Collective, Mallory
Wyckoff say.
That the best critique
of the bad
is the embodiment of the better.
The best critique
of the bad is the
embodiment of the better.
I love that. I feel like it's a place
that I can put my dissonant
energy. Instead of getting
stuck in the dissonance,
paralyzed by it. What if that was
the energy that fueled me, that
fueled us to embody
the better. The best critique
of war is
the embodiment of peace.
The best critique of scarcity
is the embodiment of provision.
The best critique of loneliness
is the embodiment
of belonging. The best
critique of polarization
is the embodiment of proximity.
The best critique
of apathy
is the embodiment of
empathy. The best
critique of dehumanization
is the embodiment of
kindness. The
best critique of injustice
is the embodiment of
love.
A couple
weeks ago I accepted an invitation
from my friend and colleague
Colin Packer to
join him and another
friend of ours, David Park,
at the Dallas Field
Office of Immigration
and Customs Enforcement,
also known as ICE.
Colin had been
invited by a grassroots
organization called
Vicinos Unidos, DFW,
led by several Chicana
women who are showing up
every day at the field
office to help migrant folks
know their rights and to raise
awareness about the mistreatment
of our undocumented neighbors
by ICE.
Colin and David and I were there
and we were invited specifically
because we are white
clergy persons.
Unfortunately and not
surprisingly, ICE agents
respond much differently
to white male clergy members
than they do to our brown
female colleagues.
They yell and curse and make threats to brown
women, but when a white clergy
person is present, they
are respectful and calm.
So our invitation
was to show up and share
the privilege that comes with our being
white to our non-white colleagues
so that they could do their work
more safely, more
effectively.
The leaders of Vicinos
Unidos asked us to find some
way to identify ourselves
as clergy with either
a stole or a collar, and that's why
I'm wearing this tonight.
Both so that ICE would
know that we were clergy,
but also so that our
neighbors would not wonder if
we were casual ICE agents
ourselves and become
suspicious of
Vicinos Unidos
and their work there.
So we borrowed three stoles, one
of which I'm wearing from our
dear friend and colleague, Pepa Paniagua,
who some of you know.
She's a Presbyterian minister
and she's got stoles and spades
apparently.
It's the first time I've ever worn one.
This is the second time I've ever worn one.
It feels a little weird, honestly,
but isn't it pretty? It's so beautiful.
Yeah?
So one Friday,
a couple weeks ago, we arrived
a little bit before 6 a.m.
in our stoles.
We met the team, we stood on the sidewalk
outside the field office, ready
to help however we were needed, but
mostly just to stand
there.
Occasionally cars would come toward us
down this industrial
West Dallas street, and if
the cars were moving fast and sometimes
blaring music, they were probably
ICE agents checking in
for their shift. I noticed
in big letters on the back of
one truck entering the employee
parking lot, Jesus saves.
I could feel
the tension and anger in my
body as those cars
raced by, many without license
plates, so that they couldn't
be identified. I noticed
as I looked over that my
friend and colleague David was
waving at the ICE agents
as they came in.
And that humanized them
for me. I was like, oh, I needed that.
I felt the difference,
the opposition there.
And some would see the
stoles and they would wave back at us.
Oh, something
felt shifted.
We wondered if
they were worried about their own families.
We wondered if their families
were worried about them.
If the cars were
moving slowly down the street,
they were usually our neighbors showing up
for their immigration
check-in appointments.
Our colleagues would wave down the slow
moving cars and invite them to talk.
And if they were willing, they would pull in to
an adjacent parking lot where
our colleagues would let them know that ICE
was detaining high numbers
of people showing up
for their routine
immigration check-ins. They encouraged
them to sign a form that would
allow Vecinos Unidos
to contact their family,
to be able to track them in the
system, otherwise there'd be no way
to know where they went,
where they were, what their
status was.
Detainees are sometimes transferred out
of state on purpose to
make it difficult to impede
their deportation process.
Our colleagues
also encouraged them to park
in the adjacent lot and not in
the ICE parking lot because
ICE has contracts with
local towing companies to impound
cars that stay in their
lot. If they came with family
members, our colleagues encouraged
their family members to leave
because ICE agents would
often ask, do you have family waiting
for you? And if they do, it's
not uncommon for ICE to go out
in the parking lot and detain
the family members as well.
Occasionally
we were asked to pray for
our neighbors who were walking to
the field office for their appointments.
And we prayed for peace
and protection
as they trembled.
Sometimes clergy
members were asked to
escort our colleagues and
neighbors to the door of the field
office to inquire about their family members
who had been inside for longer than
expected and might be
detained. I watched as one pregnant woman
came back with her
small child
and returned from asking about her husband.
She wept
as she learned that he had been detained.
Our colleagues gave her a place to
sit and food to eat.
They played with her son as
she processed the news that
she had just received.
I listened as David asked
Noemi, one of the founders
of Vicinos Unidos
DFW, how she came
into this work. And with
tears in her eyes, she shared
how her own father had
been deported when she was young.
She knows what
it's like, and she wants to help
other people who are in similar
circumstances. And so
she gets up every day
early to come to the field office
to help her neighbors
before she goes in to
her full-time job.
Noemi might not
use this language, but she and
her colleagues are
walking in the light of
the Lord. In the
midst of the dissonance of
detention and mass
deportation and mistreatment of
undocumented neighbors, in the midst
of injustice, they accepted
the invitation to participate
in God's peace
and justice and
goodness. To critique the bad
by embodying
the better. To anticipate
with their active bodies
the renewed and healed world
that is to come. The world
we hope for in the second
coming of the Christ
in this Advent season.
I wonder,
how might the
Spirit be inviting you
to walk in the light of the
Lord this Advent?
To embody the goodness
of God.
Where do you long
for more peace
and goodness and justice
and belonging around you?
What opportunities
to embody
those longings is the
Spirit sending
your way?
We don't have to fabricate
the opportunities.
We simply have to pay attention
for what the Spirit might be
sending toward us
and cooperate with it.
Go with the flow
of it. And if it
seems daunting,
I hear you. There's some risk
in accepting such an invitation.
I am usually pretty
anxious to accept the invitation
myself. So,
it's normal. You're in good
company. And I hope
you'll be kind to yourself in the midst
of the dauntingness of it.
The good news is that
the invitation is to
us collectively.
Let us walk
in the light of the Lord.
This embodiment work is something
we get to do together.
Something
I got to do with my brothers, Colin
and David.
If we long for peace in our world,
let us be a community
of peace. If we
long for belonging in our world,
let us be a community
of belonging.
If we long for the recognition
of the image of God in all of
humanity, let us be a community
that recognizes the image of God
in each other.
If we long for
generosity in our world, let us be a
community of generosity.
If we long for justice in our
world, let us be a community
of justice.
Come, let us
walk in the light
of the Lord.
In the name of the Father, and of the
Son, and the Holy Spirit.
Amen.
It is time for communion.
At the table, we
practice open communion.
So, all are welcome to
participate who wish to.
We go row by row
from the front to the back
to this center aisle all the way up
to receive the bread and the cup.
As you take the cup,
just know that the red is
wine, and the white is juice.
And you are welcome to
spend some time in prayer, or kneeling
up here at the front, or to return to your seat.
Whatever is most comfortable
and preferable to you.
This is the
table, not of
the church, but of the Lord.
It's made ready
for those who love Him,
and for those who want to love Him
more. So, come.
You who have much
faith, and you who have
little. You who have
been here often, and you
who have not been here long.
You who have tried to follow,
and you who have failed.
Come, because
it is the Lord who invites you.
It's His will that those
who want Him should meet
Him here.
Come to the table.
. . .
Tonight, we're going to
end with a prayer.
It's pronounced
Sushipe.
But Charles is actually
the one who introduced me to this.
The words are so beautiful
and powerful. I know it
might be new for some of you, as we've
only done it once or twice here.
But if you guys would stand with us
in this prayer, and just
receive this
as you go into your week.
Come.
And let it lead us into that
freedom, that hope for what is
to come, that embodiment of
walking in the light of Christ.
. . .
Would you
take, Lord,
and receive
my liberty,
my memory,
my understanding,
and my
will,
all that
I call
my own?
Give
me
only
your
loving grace.
. . .
Give me
only your
loving grace.
. . .
You have
given all
to me,
to you, Lord.
I return
it.
Everything
belongs
to you.
Do with
it what
you will.
Give
me
only
your
love
and grace.
Your
love and
grace.
That
is
enough.
That
is
enough
for
me.
For
. . .
Give me
only
your grace and
for
me.
Your
love and
grace.
Thank you so much for
joining us
today.
We're glad
you joined us.
Generosity is a key
aspect of life, of adoration,
and worship.
To give financially,
you can scan the QR code
or visit the table
at thetabletx.org.
If you call the table
home but don't currently
have a meetup,
you may go into
the table,
tx.org, and there are several
meetups that you can choose from
and find one that fits your
schedule and your time
and
have a meetup with
the different folks in the community.
And also
if you are not part of a ministry
team and you are interested in that,
we have several
ministries that
you can join if that's something
that sounds like you would like to do.
There's the host team and the
AV team and also
our praise team and our kids ministry.
So you can find
something that works
for you.
All right, let me send you
out with this benediction.
You may hold your hand down in a
posture to receive
or just open your
hearts to these words.
You are a child
of God.
You
are a child
of God.
This is true on your
best day
and this is true on your worst day.
So as
you go into your week ahead
with its yet to be determined
highs and lows and everything in between,
go
filled with the assurance
that you are loved,
that you are
worthy, and that you
are accepted
just as you are.
And go filled with God's
Holy Spirit and the
desire to extend these same
gifts of grace and unconditional
love to everyone you come in
contact with.
Be blessed.
Have a great week
and we'll see you again next Sunday.
Bye.
For me.